good evening everybody and welcome
rochford district council's remote
council meeting
and a form of a warm welcome also to
anybody watching this
via the live stream
members since our last meeting we have
sadly lost one of our fellow councillors
councillor diane hoy it is appropriate
for cows to honor her with a minute's
silence
diane represented the residence of hull
bridge as a district councillor for
eight years
she's a big loss to the district of
watchful and will be missed by me
and all her fellow councillors as well
as the residents
whom she represented members
please click on the raise hand icon if
you would like to say a few words
counselor western thank you chairman
chairman as the county council for
holbridge albert ward i would like to
express
my sadness to the passing of councillor
mrs diane hoy
a fellow war councillor who i have had
the pleasure to work with
on several occasions i understand the
heart of it the family have gone through
and she will be missed by the residents
of holbridge thank you chairman
thank you count council western council
button
thank you on behalf of the conservative
group of rockford district council
i would like to take a few moments to
pay tribute to diane hoy
and express our sadness following the
loss of our fellow councillor
on the 11th of september
i've only known diane for a very short
time
and that was as a colleague within this
chamber
she was first elected to rochford
district council as a councillor for
holbridge
in 2011 representing the green party
whatever divides us politically the one
thing
which unites us all is our common
personal commitment
and determination to support the
residents we represent
in the very best way possible
diane together with her husband
councillor michael hoya at her side
has done that superbly well
she was passionate hard-working and
caring
and as a result the holbridge community
have benefited
in so many ways over the past nine years
with her significant contribution
it was an honor along with the deputy
leader
councillor sheryl rowe to stand in ferry
road hulbridge last monday
as the funeral cortege passed so that in
our very small way
we could pay tribute to diane
everyone we spoke to that day had such
warm words to say about diane
she will be sadly missed our heartfelt
condolences
go to michael and all the family thank
you chairman
thank you council button council mrs
mason
thank you mr chairman
diana said that it was an honor and a
privilege
to represent the people of holbridge and
that statement alone
demonstrates the kindness of diane who
was always thinking of everyone else
john and i were in diane's words
honoured and privileged to have worked
with diane on the council
and her positive insightful and
constructive manner
in representing her residents shone
through
everything she did diane
never said no to a request for
assistance
you get to know someone really well when
you work with them for a period of time
and we were fortunate to also become
family friends
and diane's love for her family was
obvious
it would be hard for many people to
accept the loss of such a kind
warm and welcoming person and our
thoughts and prayers are with diana's
family
especially michael and her children
thank you
thank you councillor mrs mason
councillor wilson
thank you chairman i'd like to say a few
words and tribute to diane hoy
diane was a very down-to-earth person
and she'd always go out of her way to
help people
she had a real strong sense of social
justice and she was always ready to go
the extra yard to help her residents
particularly those that were vulnerable
diane was a real tough cookie and she
was always positive in her outlook
i remember standing outside a polling
station on an unseasonably cold day
diane was receiving treatment at the
time but she still came
out as always determined to play her
part
when concerned residents came up and
asked her how she was diane cheerily
told each one that she was fine
but once they're gone diane in her
understated matter-of-fact way
said that there was no point in her
complaining there was always someone
else
worse off than her diane was fun to be
with socially
and was always good company she was
devoted to michael
and their children joshua and emily and
to her wider family
in this saddest of times i hope that
they will be able to find some comfort
from the many warm tributes paid to
diane by so many residents
i've lost a good friend and the
residents of holbridge have lost a
hard-working
and determined councillor diane rest in
peace
thank you councillor wilson councillor
hawkway you chairman
um i've just got um
a small little snippet to um
to say just that emphasizes
that diane was someone who was prepared
to go a little bit extra and to to be
very helpful to
uh to people who who asked for her
their assistance and it's just um that
tina myself was looking at some photos
and
we come across one with diane uh with
tina uh
just about a couple of years ago when
she came over to wake princess to help
uh with a bit of campaigning and um she
when we were asking for for assistance
from some some other people diane was
the first
to to volunteer um and it's a lovely
photo
um of her and tina on a nice sunny day
and i remember that day because it was
a really enjoyable day and i think diane
enjoyed herself coming over
to wakering and that's how i remember
her
and and it's very sad situation
that she's no longer here to help others
and that's all i've got to say
thank you thank you councillor
councillor wilkinson
thank you chairman um i actually haven't
got anything prepared
like some of the others um but i do want
to
pay tribute not just to die out but to
michael as well um
i think it goes without saying that
every member here and officer
was not only saddened but shocked by the
sad news we received a couple of weeks
ago
um and i think the reason why i was so
shocked was because
both diane and michael certainly most of
us
didn't and i think uh stuart wilson's
alluded to this
also already you know she just prepared
and carried on and
we didn't realize just how serious the
situation was
um and i think that just goes to show
just what the type of people that
mr mrs hoy are um and and you know how
they've dealt with this
um my heart goes out to michael um and
everyone that's that's known and loves
diane
um and like every member here i'm sure
will be here and drop everything if
anybody within the hoy family needs any
help
um i just wanted to say something so
thank you thank you
thank you council wilkins councillor
stanley
thank you chairman uh i'd just like to
say a couple of words for diane hoy on
behalf of the
liberal party she was a very very well
liked
person on this side of the fence she
did exactly what she said she would do
she was very
straightforward no-nonsense person
and we all loved her to bits she will be
sorely missed
and uh i i wish
if anything that we can do for for the
family for michael
help him in any way we will do so
um and i send my sincere
thoughts to the family uh um
and and she was a lovely lady thank you
thank you council stanley
councillor mr hoy
thank you chairman um tracy is much
harder than i thought it would be
actually
and it was really nice to hear all those
um
words that that members have spoken
about dying and
i i know there are other counselors here
who've been through the same process as
i'm going through now and um
i don't think any of us can realize what
it's like until we've gone through it
ourselves and um you have my db sympathy
as well even though it may have been
some years ago
or even more recently um
again i i'll be very brief i really just
want to say thank you very much
to all those members who've sent the
cards and letters
um to me they are they're very nice and
they are
very helpful for both myself and the
children and and as i've been
said before the wider family and
also again to the members who
came along to the funeral and stood
along frey road or some of the side
routes
um and they were joined by mark francois
as well who kindly came along and paid
his respects
and also a large number of residents of
holbridge which were
very touching indeed um i won't say much
more but i
i know i did put this on the um asked
for it to be put on the um friday drop
but i just wanted to read it again to
everybody
um these were very much dyn's last words
diane b and diane decided to write a
letter to everybody
to be read at her funeral but obviously
not many people were at the funeral
unfortunately
um these are the final words the
residents of holbridge
and in her words to the people of
holbridge
it has been an honor and a privilege to
have served you for the last eight years
my last words to you are to be kind to
one another
um i'd just like to leave you with those
thoughts and perhaps
we can all be kind to one another not
just our residents
and i'm sure we will in the future thank
you very much for allowing me to speak
thank you councillor members
we will now observe a minute silence in
honour of councillor diane hoy
thank you members
members i shall now take item agenda
item one apologies for absence
we have received apologies from
councillors
phil shaw and jamie burton are there any
others members
also james newport chairman
thank you council stanley that will be
noted
agenda item two minutes of the meetings
held on the 14th of july 2020 and the
extraordinary meeting held on the 8th of
september 2020
members are you happy for me to sign
into a course of minutes of the council
held on the 14th of july and
and of the extraordinary council held on
the 8th of september
i will assume agreement unless you
unless anyone clicks on the raised hand
icon
members they have been agreed thank you
members item 3 of the agenda
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
none indicated thank you
gender item for members announcements
from the chairman
leader or head of paid service
members you may recall that um in the
last municipal year
um my charities my nominated charities
were the rnli
and the alzheimer's society last friday
i'm pleased to announce that i i
presented a check to the rnli
for the sum of 4950.74
all charities at moment are struggling
and i'm pleased that we did
a little bit to assist the rnli a
similar check
will go in due course to the alzheimer's
society
i'm particularly pleased with that
amount that we collected bearing in mind
that
two of my charity events were cancelled
and i'd like to thank all of those who
assisted me
in my charity endeavors and all of those
that contributed
thank you councillor woodson
chairman thank you um with your
permission chairman i would like to
make a statement in respect of the
current
copied 19 pandemic and rockford district
council
i have received a number of questions
following the announcement by essex
county council
on the 13th of october that informally
asked the government to raise the co-bid
alert level those borough and district
authorities within the administrative
boundary
of essex county council for medium
as lowest tier 1 to high
medium middle tier 2.
as members will now know the secretary
of state
did indeed move us to the higher tier 2
category this took effect at one minute
past midnight
on saturday the 17th of october
by way of some background for members on
friday 9th of october
all council leaders with the exception
of south end and tharak
which of course are unitary authorities
were invited to a meeting convened by
the leader of message county council
councillor david finch a short
presentation
was given by dr mike gogoty director of
public health essex county council
showing infection rates across the
county and projected
growth and comparison rates he explained
his rationale
and provided supporting evidence before
suggesting
making an approach to the secretary of
state
the key headlines and data have since
been shared
and are more widely in the public domain
a similar presentation was also made to
mps across the county
the compelling message was that whilst
infection rates
vary across the county and relative to
other parts of the country
they are still quite low however
essex is no different to what has been
seen in the high infection areas
and unchecked the spread of the virus is
on a similar growth
trajectory gogerty's clear advice
and very strong recommendation was that
whilst
infection levels are still low it would
be preferable
to take proactive measures to control
the rate of growth
it is important that members understand
the role of essex county council in this
situation
any decision to petition the secretary
of state
is legally that of the director of
public health
who is employed by essex county council
any decision to move authorities between
tiers
is the decision solely of the secretary
and state
rochford district council in common with
all districts
boroughs and chelmsford city council
sits beneath the county council
and is therefore directly impacted
given rochford's close proximity to
south end
i have to place on record my personal
disappointment
that as a unitary authority authority
south end
has chosen not to adopt the same
strategy as essex county
tharak also as a unitary has also chosen
not to be included in the essex wide
approach
albeit that evidence within the last few
days suggests there is significant
growth
in infection rates there
essentially we are seeing exponential
growth
in cases of comet 19 and i am satisfied
that essex county council
would not have called for this action
unless it was thought absolutely
necessary to curb transmission rates
and ultimately prevent deaths i am happy
to stand by that decision
but at the same time i do not
underestimate the concerns
about the economic impact of increased
covered restrictions
which i totally understand
however we have to work within the
three-tier system
imposed by central government our status
within the high tier
will be reviewed every two weeks by the
government in conjunction
with essex county council if we comply
and i stress the individual
responsibility we all have in this
respect to comply
with the restrictions whilst there is no
certainty
there is every chance that the data will
improve
and our status within the high tier will
be as short as possible
there is a basic principle here in that
the sooner
we get in to stop the spread of this
virus the sooner we can get
out of it but we're not there yet
and the proactive decisions taken by the
director of public health
are intended to make sure that infection
rates
do not increase out of control
but this virus is new to everyone on
this planet and governments
scientists and health officials are
still learning
and there are very wide opinions but all
with the same objective
which is to eradicate this wretched
virus so all we can do
is work on what we know and take
well-intentioned steps
based on that knowledge and to my mind
it is important that we act now
in order to save lives minimize as far
as possible the pressure
on hospitals support our local economy
and shorten the period that we have
enhanced restrictions in place
thank you chairman that completes my
statement
thank you council water members i shall
now take
agender item 5 public questions and
member questions on notice
of which there are none
agenda item 6 business from last meeting
members does anybody have any questions
relating to business from the council
meetings held on the 14th of july 2020
and or the 8th of september 2020
no one's indicating thank you members
agenda item seven to note the minutes of
the executive commit and committee
meetings held between the period first
of july 2020
to the 6th of october 2020
are these noted members i would assume
your agreement unless
you click on the raised hand icon
thank you members that's been agreed
agenda item eight members to consider
any reports from the executive and
committees to council
item eight one report of the review
committee
annual report 2019 stroke 20
council sparing vice chairman the review
committee will introduce this report
thanks council sparing thank you
chairman
um as the report says members this is
our annual report on the
works and tasks undertaken by the review
committee over the past year
for a number of reasons uh situations
developed
that the presentation is exactly in line
to what has happened in previous years
although members did express their
disappointment
it wasn't a more comprehensive and
in-depth assessment of the works
undertaken by the review committee
while there is a recommendation on on
this item
members can i reassure you that already
plans
and statements and paperwork are in hand
to improve the situation
for the years ahead and it will be a far
more comprehensive
and in-depth annual report on that basis
chairman unless there's any questions i
would
uh suppose the recommendation is
proposed that the council receives
and resolves to receive the annual
report as appended
thank you chairman thank you council
sparring
um is there a seconder
all secondary chairman councillor lauren
phil
laurene shaw
members you've all heard that report and
the recommendation
on page paragraph 2.1 of the report on
page 8.1.1
that the council receives the annual
report i will assume agreement
members unless anyone clicks on the
raised hand icon
is that received members
that has been received thank you members
sorry my apologies members
i apologize members um item agenda item
8
2 report of the executive quarter 1 2020
stroke 21 financial management
and performance report council smith
portfolio holder for finance will
introduce
this report council smith thank you
chairman
um the report reflects the quarterbomb
financial report which has been
presented to executive
obviously this report reflects financial
activity in
april may and june which was obviously
at the height of the lockdown
and clearly reflects the start of
financial challenges that we're going to
face
during the year um the council of
the work of the council has still been
ongoing beneath
um uh or all of the information that's
presented
and if it were possible to somehow strip
out the
covid related factors i think that
um we we would still see a healthy
council
underneath it all but i would
particularly
highlight the the impact of coverage
related factors
particularly in car parking at the back
end of
of the report
that that said there is a recommendation
printed on
8.2.2 which i
recommend which reflects some repo
reprofiling of capital expenditure
which is has become a necessary
requirement i'll move that
recommendation chairman
thank you thank you councillor smith
council smith do you have a seconder
i can second that so listen thank you
for the meal any questions members
no questions members there is as
councillor smith indicated there is one
recommendation arising from the report
the set out of paragraph 2.1 on page
8.2.2
it reads as follows that 2.67 million of
the planned 2020
21 capital program be pro
be reprofiled into future years has set
out an appendix 3 of the report
members i will conduct a vote by roll
call
of names for recommendation 1 when i
call your name please
indicate if you wish to recorded vote or
if you are wishing
for or against the motion or you wish
to abstain
counselor mrs belton
no recorded vote and for the
recommendation
thank you councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and for the
recommendation thank you councillor
cannell
[Music]
no recorded votes and four thank you
chair
thank you councillor mr carter
no recorded vote and four thank you
councilman mrs carter
thank you chair um abstain
on both items
yes thank you myself and i recorded your
vote
and for the motion counselor
fd you know we called it vote and for
the motion chairman thank you
councillor eves
thank you councillor gooding
councillor gooding no recorded vote
and for the recommendation thank you
chairman
councillor hazelwood
you're recording bolton forward thank
you
council hawkway now recorded though and
abstain
thank you council support no recorded
vote and abstain and may have my vote
recorded as abstaining please chairman
thank you you will hudson no recorded
vote
and four thank you councillor
no recorded vote and four
councillor mr lucas gill
no recorded vote and four thank you
council mrs lumley
now and for thank you councillor mrs
mason
against a recorded vote abstain
and will you record my abstention thank
you we will
council mrs mason council mrs macpherson
no recorded vote and four thank you
chairman
thank you councillor mr merrick no
and four thank you cancer no recorded
vote and
four councillor mrs pavlin no
and for councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and four thank you
councillor mrs shaw
no recorded vote and for the
recommendation thank you
councillor mr smith no recorded vote
for thank you council sparing no
recorded vote for
council council stanley
no recorded vote and abstain and can i
have my abstention
recall you please you can counsel
stanley council steptoe
i recorded vote and four thank you
councillor ward
no recorded vote for chairman thank you
thank you councillor webb no recorded
vote and four thank you chairman
thank you council mrs weston mary
according to voting for
chairman thank you council wilkinson
9 9-4 thank you council williams
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
four thank you
thank you council wilson thank you
chairman
no recorded vote and abstain councillor
woodson
thank you gentlemen no recorded vote and
four thank you
members i shall come back to you
remember that has been agreed there were
28 votes for
sixth abstention and there'll be no
recorded vote
thank you members
members i shall now take item eight
three
report of the standards committee's
working
uh report sorry so i said again report
of the standards committee report of the
standards committee working group
counselor joe mcpherson chairman of the
standards committee will introduce this
report
councillor mrs mcpherson thank you
chairman
yes it is a little bit of a mouthful
there um so
yes in front of members they have item
8.3
um is the report the standards committee
working group
the report there is in front of everyone
uh
the recommendations uh
start on page eight
three point three moving on to the
attached appendix and i put these to the
full
council for their consideration thank
you chairman
council western
thank you chairman um german i'd like to
move
an amendment to recommendation one if i
may please
you certainly can please continue
um the first paragraph i i think
is the same the second paragraph
at the end of the second sentence
beginning
that an amount up to 1500
replace the words a majority of group
leaders
with the chairman of standards committee
and the chairman of the standards
committee working group
okay is that it council western that's
that's the uh
yes uh that's the recommendation uh
chairman please
do you have a second council western
chairman if i can come in uh i'm happy
to second that thank you
thank you
kevin it's like to interrupt is it
possible that we
that um you could ask councillor weston
just repeat
what the amendment is because i didn't
actually catch it all i don't know
whether anybody else didn't apologize
but um i'll just start to know what it
is we've been we're gonna be voting on
so i didn't catch it all
council wilkinson if you bear with me i
shall read the amended
amended recommendation bear with me two
minutes member
remembered members the amended
recommendation is as follows
one that the current arrangements for
funding attendance for individual
members of the council at external
meetings or conferences
be confirmed with the addition of the
requirement for the member to provide
feedback bracket either written or
verbal broadcast bracket
within three months of attending to the
rest of the council as follows
at an amount of up to 1500 be identified
each year out of the member training
budget for individual members
to be able to request attendance at
external conferences stroke
training courses the allocation of such
training to be subject to the agreement
of the chairman of the standards
committee
and the chairman of the standards
committee working group
the reason for refusal or acceptance
would be on the basis
of the benefit to this council and
financial
considerations
council steptoe
thank you chairman i'm not sure whether
you'll want to take this at this point
but i
i wanted a point of clarification on
2.01 in brackets 2
and dependent on that the answer i
receive as
i may wish to make an amendment to that
paragraph
so you may wish to deal with the other
one first i'm not sure what you want to
do
yes okay
thank you councillor steptoe i shall um
deal with the amendment
first um
and we shall have a vote when i call
your name members
please indicate whether you wish to have
a recorded vote
you're a for or against the amended
amendment
as proposed by council western and
seconded by council
council wooden german there are two
people
well i'll take the vote first council
lucas gill
councillor mrs belton
chairman sorry justin sorry sorry on a
point of order
uh i started to interrupt to uh
councillor belton um if we're going to
take a vote how can we debate the
motion after the vote's been taken
council wilkinson we will we will have a
debate after we've taken the vote
because it may well be defeated
not a point of order it's not possible
to debate something after it's been
voted
on
we are only voting on the amendment
members
yes
point of order we can't debate an
amendment after it's been voted on
kelsey is quite right
members i apologize we shall have a
debate on the amendment first
and then a vote so we've got councillor
we've got council we've council
steptoe's already been isn't he
council council
thank you jim sorry i'm just fiddling
around my screen
um yeah so i just wanted
yes thank you thank you chairman and i
just wanted to ask some clarification if
i may and again from from council of
western because um
uh and i may be getting getting it wrong
i think i know what's
uh what's happened that's a reason for
this particular um
paragraph to be included within the
report because i know that there was a
request for some
uh for some external training and it did
cause a little bit of controversy i
think which within about the last couple
of months
um i mean i personally every time it's
come to me i've
you know i'm i've been ninety-nine
percent of so i've been happy with it
and agreed it
i i understand and i read this
the wording that's here at the moment um
and i thought i'd read something
somewhere that said the agreement of the
majority of the group of leaders and
it's not
written in front of me um but i thought
that's what it read and i thought well
yeah that makes sense
because so long as you know there's five
group leaders and so long as the
majority agree you don't have
everybody to agree but i understand this
amendment is now changing that and
taking out the hands of the group
leaders
and and in fairness it predates my time
of the council as to when it every
winter group is so i don't know what
thought process was behind that um and
now i've been taking out
our hands completely to the chairman and
vice chairman of the standards committee
so i'd just like to sort of understand
the rationale behind that before
i can make an informed decision to vote
on it if that's that's that's
okay council western do you wish to
comment on that
i think it felt that um we should have
just
just two members to um agree the using
the
the budget of up to 1500 for any any
outside track of any training
so i've just sort of changed it from the
majority of group leaders
to the chairman of the standards
committee and the chairman of the
standards working group chairman
okay
council wilson do you wish to speak
yes thank you chairman um
i'm not sure if i misheard um but when
councillor western
um put forward the amendment the the bit
that i thought
was the um the amendment was about
taking out
of all group leaders and adding in the
chairman and vice chairman of the
standards committee but when you read
the
the paragraph out you mentioned um
three months with it reporting back
within three months but that
doesn't appear within the text and i
don't believe that was what was
proposed by councillor weston unless i
misheard
um
she said there was no change we're
checking that point council wilson
chairman may i just may i just say
something chairman it's it's
councilwoman
the training is within the remit the
standards committee
therefore it should be better to stay
within
the remit of the chairman standards
committee chairman
sorry
council wilson to answer your point um
the first paragraph of that
recommendation is unchanged from the
original
okay thank you chairman
um councillor mrs christine mason
thank you mr chairman i think some of
the confusion here has arisen
because the recommendation is printed in
item 8.3 certainly what i've got on my
screen
is not what was agreed in the standards
committee my understanding is that it
was
as someone has alluded to quite
correctly the allocation of such
training to be subject to the agreement
of the majority
of group leaders also that as
someone else has actually again referred
to that the
that the final paragraph
that following the conference course the
memory required to provide
feedback either written or verbal to the
rest of the council and that was within
should have been within three or three
month period
to clarify the reasoning for this
yes standards is responsible for
training
but it's also responsible to the council
but also standards and training affect
all members from all groups
the rationale by putting all group
leaders in at the time
was to make sure that there was some
democracy
and some fairness applied to this
what has happened in the past to my
knowledge the only people that have
taken advantage of this
uh some which is quite significant in
the
current climate have been conservative
group members now that's not a problem
in itself
as long as it's deemed to be
fair and open to others and that's why
the reference by all group leaders was
put in
because of the practicality with five
group leaders
the decision was suggested and the
recommendation was although not as
printed
was that it was the majority of group
leaders so that there was
a speedier result
um as far as i'm aware some of these
courses can be
up to 500 pounds some are more than that
they're certainly usually over 100
pounds
and they they we really should
in the present climate that we have make
sure that money that is spent
is spent the benefit of the whole
council by
changing it as the recommendation from
council
western to the chairman of the standards
committee
and the um vice chair
i think it was in the standards
committee it makes it a political
decision
what the original decision was which was
the agreement of all groupies
was to take politics out of that
decision
so that's the rationale before that so i
can't support a motion
that says for the chair and the vice
chair
because it's very nature it's divisive
and
what i would hope was that this council
would try and be fully inclusive
thank you mr chairman yeah thank you
councilman mrs mason
counselor stanley
yes thank you chairman um i understood
that this was
the whole the benefit of this uh
sum and what it's for was for
the whole council not just part of the
council or just one party
i don't like to see it put
down to one part
part of the council it should be
and democratically should be
a decision by all parties and we are all
part of the council
this idea is just taking away
the leadership from those parties
as they mean nothing to the council and
i do feel
that this is just one step beyond
and should not be taken thank you
thank you council stanley council
steptoe
um you're debating the amendment on
um item 2.1 in brackets
one my question and possible amendment
is for the next item which is 2.1
in brackets two so
i think you need to be taking them until
sonia will convert
confirm this you need to be taking the
amendment on the
first item in that section before i go
ask the questions on the second because
that just cloud the issue
that is correct council steptoe we
haven't got
to item twos yet
councillor hookway
thank you chairman um
asia i haven't heard a um
logical or appropriate reasoning for
changing
what seems to be a uh a workable uh
situation um i have been a group leader
in the past and i have been
partying to being asked uh
for my view or my approval for
um matters relating to uh
uh training and uh whether someone um
should be um allowed
to to go on particular courses um and it
seems perfectly reasonable
as uh training is a matter for the
all members of the council that uh this
should
be put before um uh
group leaders and therefore um it seems
sensible that
your majority of your group leaders um
making the decision on this matter
is is appropriate so
i still do not understand
what is the reasoning
and i'd like it to be explained to me
for making this change
if it isn't just a political move
thank you thank you councillor hawkway
members just to clarify any member can
put forward details of a training course
for attendance
whatever their group counselor
macpherson
thank you chairman um you've actually
just clarified exactly what i was going
to say for councillor stanley
um as you rightly said any group can put
forward so
that this um thing about being only one
group is
entirely incorrect and they will
all be requested to provide a report
which will be circulated
to all members as well so there isn't
any um one party this will be
provided to all parties training will be
of benefit
to all councillors regardless of who
goes on to there
um councillor hookway actually just
asked about
any reasoning behind this now
obviously councillor mrs wester may come
back
but one thing that i have understood in
the past unless i'm wrong
is that this has taken some time
um to go past leaders
before so my thoughts on some of the
reasoning here could be
to make it a swifter and quicker process
for people to be able to attend some
training thank you chairman
thank you councillor macpherson
councillor hoy
thank you chairman i have a problem
on this with of a technical nature and
i'll
refer you back to the comments made by
councillor mrs mason
i'm reading from the minutes of the
standards committee of the 17th of
september
and this the recommendation is that an
amount of up to 1500 pound be identified
each year out of the member training
budget for individual members
to be able to request attendance at
external conferences training courses
the allocation of such training to be
the subject to the agreement of a
majority of group leaders
now this is not what it says in our
paper work
so the recommendation that we are we
have been told have been put forward by
the standards committee
isn't the wording used by the sanders
committee and that was approved by the
standards committee by eight
votes to nil so i'm not sure what the
legality
is of us approving an amendment
to a recommendation the recommendation
which we're changing isn't the
recommendation which we're supposed to
be
approving anyway but on that basis
i can't support you i can't see how you
should go ahead i think it personally
should be deferred
to the next meeting so we can get
legality as well please chairman thank
you
we'll come back we'll come back to you
on that council hawaii thank you
councillor mcpherson has pretty much
um made made the point i i was going to
make that it seems to me that by having
one leader sign it off
just speeds the process up as opposed to
anything else because any party or any
member
can request funds for training therefore
by having one person sign that off it
seems to be a more efficient process
thank you
thank you councillor belton
council ahoy i think what you're saying
is that the
recommendation one as in the papers
is not the recommendation as
put forward by the standards committee
is that correct that is correct yes
counselor mr hoy for the benefit of
other members
i've just looked at the minutes of the
standards committee the relevant one
[Music]
and the recommendation is put forward
today
seems to be exactly the same as that
recommendation
put forward by the standards committee
um if i'm a chairman it the one i've got
in front of me
which i was sent today is different to
one in the minutes which are publicly
available on our website which i've just
looked up
the one we've received today said it
says all group leaders the one on the
that i looked up on the website says a
majority of group leaders
this is a report and it says
be identified each year the
mediterranean foreign
the agreement or recommendation agreed
by the standards committee
said that and i shall read it to you
subject to the agreement of a majority
of group
leaders which is exactly the same as in
respect of the
uh uh recommendation put forward in
today's papers
council ft somehow if thank you chairman
can i just
say that of my recollection of the
meeting standards that it is quite
correct in the paperwork i have just
opened on my
laptop and majority of group leaders and
also agree with
what kaiser macphers and the council
have been
danielle said for speed to get these
things through
and i know that we've had i know the
training course
we lost out on a much reduced rate
because it took so long to go through
all the party leads all the party
leaders thank you
sorry on a point of older chairman can i
ask why i've been saying different
paperwork to the conservative members
then please
because my paperwork which i've received
today and just opened says
all group leaders it doesn't say
majority it says all group leaders
and that's my paper study i don't know
how i can participate in a meeting if
i've been sent the wrong paperwork
point of order chairman if i may come in
uh just to maybe help
council award carry on you're on mute
council award yep sorry about that
chairman um
yeah i think on page 8.3.1
where we have the recommendations 2.1
going down
uh to 0.1 and then two in brackets but
one
yes it does actually say subject to the
agreement of the majority of group
leaders it actually says that it carries
on into
page 8.3.2 which is correct
but if you go down into the appendix
it is different it is a totally
different recommendation
at 2.2 which i think is the confusion
because it's totally different
which is on 8.3.4 just a point
pointing out members the appendix was
the original report that went to the
standards committee
which they changed which was then
changed
okay members i think that we've
debated this enough i will now take a
vote
on the amended substantive motion
as put forward by council western and
seconded
by councillor wooden and
uh for the benefit of doubt i should
i i did request some
kind of explanation for the re and
reasoning for
uh this um this uh amendment um and
the person who's put forward the
amendment hasn't provided
appropriate reasoning as far as i'm
aware
i take your account it's a matter of
about saving time but as far as i'm
aware
all these training courses are
advertised well in advance different
months in advance
and it would only be a matter of uh
appropriate administration
rather than attempting to deny uh
other groups access to a decision-making
process which they already
currently have thank you council hawkway
i'll check your point but we have
sorry robin you're all mute my love
robin you're on mute
sorry when you're on youtube i take your
point but we have debated this
enough i feel um we now will
uh take a vote before you do so i'd like
to make a statement of personal
clarification about something that's
been said
carry on councillor mrs mason thank you
it's been alluded to that the group
leaders have taken considerable time
and on the last request that we had that
is true
the reason and i think it took me about
two weeks
was because i went straight back to the
officer and asked
for details of the course i was asked to
approve a course without
any information about that course except
for the cost
that was unacceptable to me and i went
straight back and asked for the
information about the course
six days later not having heard i chased
up the officers
so any delay isn't by the group leaders
and i don't see why
we should be penalized and for
poor administration thank you thank you
councillor mrs mason
members as i've said before i shall now
take a vote on the amendment as put
forward by council western
and seconded by council wooden
and uh for uh benefit of
doubt i shall read that out again
one that the current arrangements for
funding attendance for individual
members of the council
had external training or conferences be
confirmed with the addition of the
requirement for the member to provide
feedback bracket either written or
verbal close bracket
within three months of attending to the
rest of the council
as follows that an amount of up to 1
500 be identified each year out of the
member training budget for individual
members to be able to request attendance
at external conferences stroke training
courses
the allocation of such training to be
subject to the agreement of the chairman
of the standards committee
and the chairman of the standards
committee working group
the reason for refusal or acceptance
would be on the basis of the benefit
to this council and financial
considerations
members i shall now take a vote
which will be roll call of names when i
call your name could you please let me
know whether you wish to have a recorded
vote
for or against the substantive motion
council mrs belton thank you
no recorded vote and for the motion
council mrs butcher
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
for the motion
councillor canal
for recorded vote please chair and
against
thank you councillor mr carter now
recall devoting four
thank you thank you councillor mrs
carter
thank you recorded vote please and
against
thank you myself no record if uh vote
and for the motion
counselor fd no recording voting for the
motion thank you chairman
councillor eves recorded vote and
against
the motion thank you thank you mrs
gooding
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
thank you council mr hazelwood
no record is voting against
council hawkway
recorded though and against the amended
motion
council mr hoy recorded vote and against
the
uh recommendation thank you councillor
mr hudson
no recorded vote for the amendment
uh recorded vote and against
councillor mr lucas gill no recorded
vote and four
thank you gentlemen council mrs lumley
no and four thank you council mrs mason
for a recorded vote against the
amendment
thank you council mrs mcpherson uh no
reported vote and for the amendment
thank you chair thank you councilman
eric
no and four thank you councilman
no recorded vote and for the amendment
thank you
council mrs pavlin
thank you councilman
thank you chairman no and four thank you
councillor mrs shaw thank you chairman
no
and for the amendment thank you council
mr smith
now recorded vote for thank you council
sparing
no recorded vote for council stanley
a recorded vote and against thank you
council steptoe no recorded vote and
for the amendment thank you council ward
no recorded vote and four thank you jim
thank you account sir mr webb no
recorded vote and
four thank you chairman thank you
councillor mrs weston
erie cordover and ford chairman thank
you thank you council wilkinson
recorded vote please chairman and
against the motion thank you council
williams
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
for the amendment
thank you councillor wilson for recorded
vote
and against thank you thank you
councilwood
no recording voting for chairman thank
you
members that motions has been carried
there will be a recorded vote there were
23 votes
four and 11 against thank you member
chairman with your permission if i may
counsel woodson yes thank you chairman
um
could i suggest following that that will
speed up uh the
processing but at the same time
administratively could i ask
that for any courses that are agreed for
members
the chairman of standards and of the
standards committee working group
do at least pay the courtesy of letting
all group leaders know
who they have approved to attend the
course i think that that's an
administrative
factor which would actually be helpful
for group leaders it makes sense to me
thank you council bushel
members michelle now members we shall
now take um recommendation
two um uh that
chairman excuse me chairman councillor
weston
we've got to agree
we've got to agree the new substantive
motion chairman
a yes may i make a statement of clarity
of
correction please i quoted six days
um from the officer uh responding it was
in fact
15. my apologies for misleading
thank you
you're muted german
members we shall now vote
on the substantive motion which i
previously written
wrote uh read out um
do you wish me to read it out again
i shall do so just in case
this is now the substantive motion and
we are
voting um on this one
that the current arrangements for
funding attendance for individual
members of the council had external
training or conferences be confirmed
with the addition of the requirement for
the member to provide
feedback bracket either written or
verbal closed bracket
within three months of attending to the
rest of the
council as follows that the amount of up
to 1
500 be identified each year out of the
member training budget for individual
members to be able to request attendance
at external conferences stroke training
courses
the allocation of such training would be
to be subject to the agreement of the
chairman of the standards committee
and the chairman of the standards
committee working group
the reason for refusal or acceptance
would be on the basis of the benefit to
this council
and financial considerations members
you know the format now when i call your
name please indicate whether you wish to
have a recorded vote you are for or
against
that motion council mrs belton
no recorded vote and four thank you
council mrs butcher
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
four
councillor canal
sarah's on youtube apologies uh no
recorded vote abstain thank you
councilor carter
thank you chair no recording vote m4
council mrs carter thank you chair
um no recorded vote and abstain
thank you myself now recorded vote and
for
counsellor fd no record he votes in four
thank you chairman
thank you councillor eves recorded vote
and abstain
council mrs gooding no recorded vote and
for the motion thank you chairman thank
you council hazelwood
no record is voting for thank you
council hookway no recorded vote
understand
now said mr hyde
i believe councillor has left the
meeting
council mr hawaii
i had to leave the meeting chairman
i'll come back to you counselor mr
counselor hudson
no recording vote for the motion
councillor ionu
no recorded vote and four council lucas
gill
no recorded vote m4 thank you chairman
councillor mrs lumley no and for
thank you council mrs mason
[Music]
recorded vote and against
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson
no recorded vote and four thank you
councilmerrick no and four
councilman no recorded vote and four
councillor mrs pavling no and four
thank you councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and four thank you
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman no and for councillor
smith
no recorded vote for thank you council
sparing
no and for thank you councillor stanley
no recorded vote and abstain council
steptoe
no recorded vote and four council award
no and four chairman yesterday webb
no and four thank you chairman bowser
council wilkinson uh yes recorded
voicing against police chairman
councillor williams no recorded vote and
four
hundred german council wilson
no recorded vote and abstain council
woodson
i recorded voting for councillor hoy
can i have your vote please
members i shall come back to you
remembers that motion has been passed 25
votes four two against six abstentions
and there will be no recorded vote thank
you members
members for sure now take um
recommendation
to um council western
uh thank you chairman i'd like to tell
you i'm gonna try to science interrupt
but i believe i had my hand up first
here
who is speaking
is that okay was that the case i can't
tell
what steptoe i can't tell who was first
i will ask them i'll come in straight
away i'll ask councillor weston
to uh proceed thank you
uh sorry chairman uh councillor uh mike
stepford might
say the same as what i'm saying but i'll
just just check anyway
i want to move the following amendment
to recommendation too please chairman
um in the first sentence can we delete
the word
similar to that of the development
committee
training and insert mandatory please
the second and third sentences stay the
same
and delete the fourth and the fifth
sentences
um a further course or one-to-one
training on both subjects to be offered
if other
capacity permits or externally sourced
if suitable details of further courses
to be determined by the chairman of the
standards committee and the chairman of
the working group
and the final sentence to be amended to
read members of the licensing and
appeals committee must attend licensing
and appeals training
each municipal year by the end of
september can read that again chairman
if some of the members
didn't understand what i was asking for
gentlemen if i may come back to record
council
council chairman i i i'm happy to second
that because in essence that's basically
what i was going to
suggest i am a little perturbed
several times during the course of the
first
item that you were talking about on this
you had come to me and i said several
times
that i wanted a point of clarification
and then to come back
so i feel a little bit aggrieved that um
i wasn't given that opportunity to uh to
bring forward what i was going to
suggest
but he said that i will second council
of western's motion
i apologize for not coming back to you
uh councillor steptoe
right we've got a proposal and a second
members does anybody wish to speak on
those amendments
for the sake of clarity i shall read out
the amended motion as put forward by
council western and seconded by council
steptoe
that licensing and appeals committee
training be mandatory
one calls to be offered for license
licensing training
bracket daytime and evening close
bracket one calls to be offered for taxi
appeals
training bracket daytime and evening
close bracket
members of the licensing and appeals
committee must attend licensing and
appeals training each municipal year
by the end of september
does anybody wish to have any questions
on that thank you members
christine mason that's mrs mason
counselor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i sometimes wonder
if i attend different meetings to other
members
um it's very hard to
um understand
why this has been put forward when the
monitoring officers very clearly
told us why it couldn't be done
the training for licensing and appeals
is not for the committee
it is for the members of the committee
that serve on hearings
and they have to be trained the
licensing committee members
do not have to receive training and this
seems to cause a lot of confusion
between members
um i would like the monitoring officer
to to clarify this because i don't
really think it should be
i should have to clarify it again when
it's been clarified
to the committee by an officer i don't
see how they can
insist that members of a committee
assist training that is not actually for
that committee
is for an activity that comes under that
committee
so perhaps the monitoring officer can
clarify and
advise on the advice that she gave us
last time thank you
uh mason council stanley
thank you chairman i would just uh
reiterate what
uh councillor mrs mason has said uh that
that's
that's that was actually said to us by
the officer yeah
thank you chairman if i remember
correctly the uh
angela law said that the committee
doesn't have to be trained but all
members
for the panels must be drawn from the
committees
and if the committee there's not enough
members have been trained to sit on the
licensing board
they would have to sit on the licensing
board and if it went to a pill the judge
could ask have all the members being
trained just sitting on a licensing
board and if he happened
one hasn't been trained it's a excuse to
be chucked out
and losing the pill that's why i think
this should be mandatory thank you
chairman
thank you counselor gooding
thank you chairman um as as chairman of
licensing and appeals committee
i fully endorse the amendment put
forward
by councillor weston and on the same
grounds as what
councillor fd has just put forward
himself
thank you chairman
thank you councillor gooding council
steptoe did you wish to come back
just want to first of all clarify my
hand is coming up because again
on three occasions i know i put my hand
up before the other people have put them
up
so i'm not sure what's happening there a
bit concerned but the point i wanted to
make was that
the pool of the
people that will attend the appeals
committee are drawn from the members
of the licensing committee and because
very often when these appeals are heard
we are talking of the livelihood of
a taxi driver of a business and it will
have a great effect
many years ago this function was
conducted by
um a justice of the peace or a
magistrate
it was passed over to the uh councils
some time ago
so i do feel that this is still a
quasi-legal
issue and can have and it's extremely
great effect
on study that may lose an appeal
or may lose a judgment so
i strongly recommend that it has to be
the members have to be trained
although if you attend a licensing
committee meeting
transformation is correct you don't
necessarily need to be trained with that
but for for the officers to be able to
draw on the pull
of members to attend the appeals
committee
if we make that any smaller it becomes
more and more difficult
for those officers to be out of it so
that is the reason
that i feel that the it should be for
all of the members of the licensing
committee
thank you
councillor ionu oh thank you chairman
uh i'd like to uh if it's possible
for the monitoring officer angela law to
just clarify to the members
exactly what was stated to the members
of the licensing board
before i make a decision
council hawkway
thank you chairman uh it does make me
wonder why we have some of these
committees if um
you know the committees are meant to
discuss matters like this within them
and come to a conclusion within
those committees and then bring their
recommendations to the council
and then suddenly this is all being
altered uh
full council meeting doesn't seem to be
uh uh
appropriate really but um but my point
about this is um
um as a licensed taxi driver if i was on
the licensing committee
um i might be placed on the licensing
committee and i'd be able to hear
mata's regarding licensing but i
wouldn't be able to uh
participate in any appeals so there'd be
little point in me
taking training for appeals because i
couldn't uh sit on any appeals
so would that mean that uh the mandatory
situation with regard to
uh the training would uh actually um
prevent me from
participating on the committee about the
other
uh aspect of which that committee is
formed thank you
i'd like to like to have a an answer
from
angela in relation to that matter please
thank you
thank you councillor hook way one point
i'd like to make is that uh
the full council can change the
recommendations of any committee
councillor hookway
angela law if i could ask you to comment
on the points raised by members
thank you chairman one moment
angela can you hear me
she's getting feedback
um members can you hear me yes
yes thank you chairman um counselor
and counselor fd and council steptoe is
correct
um um in what they say uh that uh
to take part in um a licensing of your
happy carriage appeal
uh you know you should have the training
however
uh the quote the amendment is about
whether the training should be mandatory
and that that actually is a decision for
the members
so um whilst the the the
numbers are correct um the decision
around
what requirements you members would want
for training is really a decision
for members tonight
thank you angela
um
council eves thank you chair
um i'm wondering if all this
conversation
is anyway how many times has the
appeals committee not been able to sit
because there hasn't been enough trained
people
on there in recent times
angela can you answer that question
sorry can we have the question
asked again that's age could you repeat
your question please
i i i'm listening to all this
conversation and i don't recall having
heard
of any appeals um
uh board
um what you've got not the committee um
having been cancelled because you did
not have enough people qualified
to attend the the panel can you advise
of any
meetings that have been cancelled in
recent times because there were not
enough qualified people
available we had four people at one
point
can you respond to that please yes yes
yes
yes
angela law can you respond to that
can you hear me i'm actually using the
vice chairman's mic um i think i believe
there was
one occasion where a member
had to um be called in last minute and
rearrange their own personal commitments
because we
because the member was able to rearrange
her
personal commitment
you're indicating you wish to speak but
you do
you have already spoken uh but as uh
second of the motion you
you have the right to uh to speak later
in the debate do you wish to speak now
i'll wait till later in the debate
chairman
councillor sorry councillor woodson
thank you chairman um i don't know i may
have got this wrong
but i've sort of picked up a perception
that there seems to be resistance by
um certain people who sit on the
licensing committee to be trained
now if i sat on a committee i'd want to
understand
even if it was sitting on the periphery
of the actual
earrings i want to be fully
understanding
um the subject on which i was sitting on
a committee for
i totally get the fact that you want a
maximum pool
and i don't perhaps i'm missing
something
but i would actually want to be fully
trained in the subject of the committee
that i was actually sitting on
this isn't a punishment this is actually
wanting to help people
so that they fully understand the
subject i don't get it chairman thank
you
thank you councillor wilson
councillor mcpherson thank you chairman
um
just a couple of points when listening
to the debate
um there was mention of why committees
when we come to full council and
then amendments are made to change
recommendations
can i say there has always been a
healthy
and good debate at standards but we have
never
always been in agreement
around this thing about mandatory
training
so you also need to look at the fact
that there are
eight members of the standards committee
that's eight members putting this
forward yes it should come before
full council full council is 37 members
so just bear that in mind and i'm
listening to why i agree with councillor
wootton
why would people not want this training
i sit on licensing and appeals it's
probably one of the most difficult roles
because as somebody has already
mentioned you are
handling people's livelihoods you're
making that decision
now i want to have the best training
somebody may argue that it's not a legal
requirement
but i can tell you it's a moral one
thank you
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson um
counselor mrs weston you're indicating
you wish to speak but you you
you're the yeah can i just can i just
say jim and i i agree what like
so mike stepso has
sorry can you hear me i agree what
counselor mike steptoe has said about
all the legalities and there was a year
um there was only four of us that were
trained to be able to attend a license
and hearing to do with that
and it was me personally you had to give
up my lead to attend
otherwise this uh the person who had to
come come forward would not have been
able to um
obviously um go go through the licensing
so i fully understand and agree what um
councillor mike stepso said and also
what council woodson so i i still
believe that this should be mandatory
and what everybody else has said on this
thank you chairman
thank you council yeah and point of all
the chairman
um i asked uh a specific question of uh
the officer in relation to uh a matter
of um
her advice in relation to this committee
uh i haven't had the answer i just
wonder if it's possible
that i could actually get an answer so i
can understand
what my personal position would be in
relation to
this committee as i say i'm a licensed
tax driver
i can't participate in appeals so
therefore if i don't
um have
uh training for appeals hearings does
that prevent me from being on
this committee and completely thinking
angela law could you respond to that
please yes thank you chad
in relation to councillor hookway he
would still be able to sit
on um uh alcohol licensing
appeals to uh obviously it will depend
on whether he has an interest
in the application but with regards to
any happy carriage any taxi licensing
appeals
it would be decided on a case-by-case
basis as to whether
he would have an interest in the case so
it doesn't necessarily mean that he
can't sit on any of the appeals
thank you angela
council award
thank you chairman i i think you know
some of the confusion that's come up is
because of the amalgamation
of both of these committees
originally they were separate and there
was separate training
and to my mind i believe that it
should have been mandatory on both of
those committees
at the time the fact that it's now been
brought together
so that all members of that committee
are both
um licensing and appeals um
i i fully agree that it should be
mandatory across the board
um and irrespective i i thought i found
in the past there were great difficulty
actually going on to the licensing
committee
because um of people who are not
necessarily
appropriately trained at the time and
and that was always a problem and i can
remember sonja
literally pulling her hair out because
she couldn't get people
on some of these committees so i feel it
is
really essential that it's mandatory
people are fully trained
and i i have to agree with the various
comments made
how important it is to the livelihoods
of those people
who are actually in front of these
committees
thank you chairman thank you council
ward
um councillor mrs mason you indicating
you wish to speak but you have already
spoken on this item
so i shall allow council williams who
wishes to speak
to speak at this conjunction council
williams
yes thank you chairman um i've been uh
that's being a a member of a previous
last year i was a member of the
committee i can't believe that this
this amendment is even being contested
the consequences of the decisions made
can
and have such a significant impact on on
someone's
livelihood they should be trained i'm
sorry i just i
i fully support this thank you
thank you councillor williams
councillor marine shaw
thank you chairman i completely agree
with what's already been said about
um having this training as mandatory i'm
on the committee i've also sat on the
pills
and without proper training i would i
believe
i would have been would have found it
hard to make the correct
decisions this training should be
mandatory thank you
thank you councillor shaw um
council steptoe and council western do
you wish to come back
council of western first please sorry no
no chairman
oh sorry council steptoe then please
thank you chairman um yes a number of
things have
been mentioned there um yes the
licensing appeals committee were
separate
committees some years ago um those that
have been on the council fund some time
we'll remember we did have for one
example one
licensing application or licensing
appeals
application of a local
hotel it was where it was so complicated
we actually
had to have people in reserve if they'd
have fallen out of the
somebody who's taken ill during the
course of the appeal process
a little bit like the courts do with a
jury service
so that does happen from time to time
when there is a very big
and serious matter
the monitoring officer also mentioned
that the the appeals
does listen to other appeals as well
there is licensing as well as the taxes
of course with the licensing side of the
committee
if the licensing committee itself is
looking at recommending policy to the
council
then surely those people that are on
that committee
need to have an understanding of the
effects of the policy they may be
looking at considering
so i cannot understand why
people do not want to have the um
the training it is very difficult job
when the appeals committees have to sit
during the course of the day
people are committed to work people are
committed to holidays
okay this particular conjunction in
there in our lives that's quite slightly
different
but on most cases it has been a
difficult job for the officers
phoning around trying to get enough
people to come forward
to actually be able to serve on the
appeals committee
so i can't endorse this strongly enough
to say that this must be
a mandatory obligation those members
that are on the
licensing appeals committee
thank you council steptoe members
i shall now take a vote on the amended
motion as put forward by council western
seconded by
council steptoe and for the avoidance of
doubt i shall read that out again
that licensing and appeals committee
training be mandatory
one calls to be offered for licensing
training bracket daytime and evening
close bracket
one calls to be offered for tax year
pills training
bracket daytime and evening close
bracket members of the licensing and
appeals committee
must attend licensing and appeals
training each municipal year by the end
of september
members there'll be a vote by roll call
you know the format
please what i call your name indicate
how you wish to vote
councillor mrs belton thank you
for a recorded vote and for the
recommendation thank you
councillor mrs butcher
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
for the recommendation
thank you councillor canal
uh four and four please chair thank you
council mr carter
yeah four and four please thank you guys
for mrs carter
thank you chair um for a recorded vote
and
thank you myself no recorded vote and
for the motion
councillor fd before we call you vote
and for the motion thank you chairman
councillor eves no recording voting for
the motion
thank you councillor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
thank you councillor hazelwood
four recorded vote and fourth in motion
council hill clay
councillor hudson no recorded vote for
the motion
thank you councillor ionu
uh recorded vote and four
thank you council mrs lumley no and for
councillor mrs mason
recorded vote abstain
council mr mcpherson recorded vote
and four thank you chairman thank you
councilman
thank you thank you council mrs rowe
thank you chairman four and four thank
you council mrs shaw
thank you chairman four and four
councillor smith no recorded vote four
council spurring four and four thank you
council stanley
four and abstain council steptoe
four and four council ward
four and four chairman thank you council
webb
thank you chairman four and four thank
you
councillor mrs weston
thank you council wilkinson
williams thank you chairman four and
four council wilson
four and four council wooden
thank you chairman four and four thank
you members i'll come back to you
members there will be a recorded vote um
and the motion amendment amendment has
been passed
4 30 abstain
three none against with a recorded vote
thank you members
members we shall now vote on the
substantive
motion um as put forward
by councillor western and seconded by
councillor steptoe
again if i want to call your name could
you please indicate how you wish to vote
you all know the format counselor mrs
belton
no and for thank you councillor mrs
butcher
no and thank you councillor cannell
four and four sure thank you thank you
council
mr carter no n4
thank you council mrs carter
thank you thank you sorry i wasn't sure
if my mic was on um
no recorded vote and upstate thank you
myself
no recorded vote and for the motion
counselor fd
a recorded vote and for the nation
council eves
councillor gooding four and four thank
you chairman
councillor hazelwood
and four thank you council hawkway
i recorded voting abstain
how's the hudson uh no recorded vote
and for the motion thank you councillor
iodo
recorded vote and four thank you
council lucas gill four and four
chairman councillor mrs lumley
no and four thank you councillor mrs
mason
a recorded vote of saying thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
four and four chairmen house america
no and four thank you councilman
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you council mrs pavlin
uh no i'm four thank you councillor mrs
rowe thank you chairman four and four
thank you council mrs shaw
thank you chairman four and four thank
you councillor smith
now recorded vote for council sparing
four and four thank you council stanley
four and abstain please thank you
council steptoe
four and four thank you council ward
council award
i'll come back to your counselor
department chairman sorry chairman
four four and four thank you
council webb thank you chairman four and
four
thank you councillor mrs weston born for
chairman
councillor four and four chairman
thank you council williams
thank you chairman that's four and four
thank you council wilson
or an abstain council wooden
thank you chairman four and four thank
you
members i'll come back to you
members there will be a recorded vote
and the motion has been passed
28 votes for five abstentions
none against thank you members
members we shall now there is a final
recommendation on this item
item recommendation three
that suggested guidelines for the
organization of premises licensing
hearings and taxi licensing hearings be
it
be as attached to the report members
there will be a vote by roll call of
names
you know the format thank you members
councillor mrs belton
now you're in four thank you council mrs
butcher
no and for thank you chairman thank you
councillor cannell
nine four thank you chair councillor mr
carter
no i'm four thank you chair council mrs
carter
thank you no an abstain
myself no and four councillor fd
no i'm four thank you chairman thank you
councillor eves
councillor mrs gooding no and four thank
you chairman
thank you what's the hazelwood
no one for councillor hawkway
no and for councillor hudson
no recorded vote for the motion thank
you
councillor ionu no record vote and for
the motion
thank you councillor lucas gill no and
for
chairman councillor mrs lumley
no and for councillor mrs mason
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you council mrs mcpherson no
and against chairman thank you counselor
mr merrick no and four
thank you council bill no and four
councillor mrs pavlin no i'm four
thank you councillor mrs rowe thank you
chairman no and
councillor mrs shaw thank you chairman
no
and four counselor smith now recorded
vote
for thank you council sparing
no and four thank you council stanley
council no and abstain
that's the step toe no and four
thank you council ward no
and four chairman thank you council webb
no and four thank you chairman mrs
weston
um for chairman thank you wilkinson
no unfortunate thank you councillor
williams
chairman that's no and for thank you
council wilson
no and four and councillor wooden
no four thank you chairman thank you
members
members there will not be a recorded
vote motion has been passed
30 votes for one against and two
abstentions
thank you
members i shall now take item eight four
of the agenda a report on the planning
policy committee
one essex coast recreational disturbance
of ida
mitigation strategy rams
spd 2020.
did somebody speak out of time
the standing orders are two and a half
hours and they're so much mistaken
twenty past nine
we still we are still in time mrs mason
20 past ten it shows you what a long
meeting it's been
thank you apologies for the mistake
thank you
as i was saying members i shall repeat
it i shall now
take item eight four report of the
planning policy committee
one essex coast recreational disturbance
avoidance
and mitigation strategy bracket rams
close bracket
supplementary planning document bracket
spd close bracket 2020
council sparing chairman of the planning
policy committee will introduce the
sitelist report
councillor sperring thank you chairman
as members will see this is a very
lengthy and in-depth report
officers gave us a substantial overview
of this situation
it effectively is a balanced uh
report assessing with ultra
interested parties how we can protect
the coast
and taking account of other requirements
are made on it for example you know
recreation this sort of thing even if we
do not join this
uh group chairman which i i strongly
recommend we should
that does not neglect our legal
responsibilities in this area
and i therefore recommend that the
council resolves the two items that are
included on page 8.4.1
thank you chairman thank you council
sparring council award
thank you chairman i would like to
second that please thank you
sorry chairman you're muted members are
there any questions
council steptoe yes thank you chairman
i'm not sure if i need to declare an
interest in this as i sit on a committee
uh coastal committee and the
environmental agency committee
uh for count on behalf of county so i'm
not sure if i need to declare an
interest
um angela law can you comment on that
please
chairman that will be noted
williams
council williams thank you chairman yeah
i also sit on the essex platform so
perhaps that should be noted too thank
you
angela if you can note that as well from
council williams at interest thank you
councillor gooding
if you could just note that i represent
uh bradwell
for uh rochester district council thank
you
thank you councillor gooding council law
do you wish to come back
oh yes thank you uh just in regards to
the flood forum i'm also a member of
that
and i believe councillor rowe is also a
member
i was just going to say that thank you
chairman
thank you council ward councillor any
other questions
sorry apologies for interrupting a
member of the flood forum
thank you councillor mrs lumley are
there any questions
yes yes
i'm a member of the crouch harbour
advisory committee
thank you councillor houserwood any
other interests to be noted members
no are there any questions members
[Music]
okay members there are three
recommendations
um put forward by council sparing and
seconded by uh council ward i intend
members to take these recommendations
together
on this item my apologies there's only
two
recommendations uh on this on this
particular item
that the essex coastal ram supplementary
planning document
spd set out an appendix b be adopted
and that the that the you said we did
report adoption statement set out in
appendix a
and c respectively be published on the
council website
thank you council sparing as i was
saying members i propose to
take those recommendations together and
i will assume agreement unless anyone
clicks on the raised hand icon
no one's indicating members
therefore when i call your name please
indicate how you wish to
vote and again you know the procedure
counselor mrs belton
no and for thank you now so mrs butcher
you no and for
chancellor connell no and for
thank you thank you councillor mr carter
no n4 thank you chairman thank you
council mrs carter
thank you yes uh sorry for
can you give this again mrs carter
please
councillor mrs carter can you give your
vote again
she's on mute i'll come back to you mrs
carter
myself no recorded voting for councillor
fd no recording voting for thank you
chairman
councillor eves now and for thanksgiving
counselor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
thank you counselor hazelwood
914. councillor
hookway
a recorded vote and for
councillor hudson no recorded vote for
the motion
thank you councillor ionu no recorded
vote and four
councillor lucas gill no
and for chairman thank you councillor
mrs lumley
no and for councillor mrs mason
no uh recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson uh no
recorded vote and four thank you
chairman
councilman merrick oh and four
councillor mild no and four
councillor mrs pavlin at 94
thank you councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman now and for
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman known for councillor
smith
no recorded vote four thank you accounts
are sparing
no and four yes sir stanley
no m4 counts to steptoe
no and four thank you council
ward no and four thank you chairman
councillor webb
no and four thank you chairman thank you
council mrs weston
and for chairman thank you council
wilkinson
no unfortunate council williams
chairman that's no and for council
wilson
no and four councillor woodson
thank you chairman councillor mrs carter
would you please
clarify your wish and how you wish to
vote please
thank you my apologies um it's no and
for
thank you come back to your members
members there's no uh recorded vote and
uh the vote was unanimous in in
favor of the recommendations thank you
members
members we shall now take item two
um on it agenda item eight four essex
coast recreational disturbance avoidance
and mitigation strategy
bracket rams close bracket partnership
agreement
2020 hyphen 2023
council sparing once again chairman of
the planning policy commission
will introduce this report thank you
chairman again another lengthy uh report
that was
given a the once-over and guidance
explained to
a number of us by our officers very
comprehensively
effectively uh chairman this is a
memorandum
effectively of understanding between all
the interested parties
to continue working on the basis of what
they've already achieved for the
uh coastal protections etc and that this
is
applies from 2020 to 2023
and we share the cost between all
interested parties chairman thank you
i therefore recommend that the
recommendations
as items 4.1 2 and 3
be accepted by the council thank you
council sparing do you have a second uh
yeah council award
yes i'd like to second that please
chairman thank you council ward
chairman you're on mute please thank you
members once again i propose that we
will vote on these recommendations
together
and i will assume your agreement unless
anyone clicks on the raised hand icon
nobody has done so so we should take all
three recommendations together
i shall read them out one that the
council enters into a partnership
agreement set out in appendix 2 at
appendix a
2. that authority be delegated to the
assistant director place and environment
to discharge the council's
responsibilities under the partnership
agreement
in consultation with the portfolio
holder for planning
and three that is agreed that the annual
costs of around 3500
be met from the existing local
development framework
reserve members please
indicate when i call your name how you
wish
to vote councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote for thank you
councillor mrs butcher
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
for
canal no in fortune thank you
councillor mr carter no of four
thank you chairman councillor mrs carter
thank you chad um no and
uh abstain thank you myself now recorded
vote and
four councillor fd no we called you
voting for thank you chairman
thank you councillor eves
councillor eaves
thank you thank you councillor mrs
gooding
no and four thank you chairman
councillor hazelwood
no one for councillor hawkway
no councillor hudson
known for council
uh no recorded vote in four
council ex councillor lucas gill
no and for chairman thank you councillor
mrs lumley
no and for councillor mrs mason
no and four thank you thanks to mrs
mcpherson
no end fourth thank you chairman
councillor merrick
no and four councillor mill
no and for councillor pavlin
no i'm four thank you yeah so mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and four thank you
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman no and for council
smith
a recorded vote for council sparing
no and four councilors stanley
no and four yeah that's a step
oh and four council ward
no and four thank you jim that's the web
no and four thank you chairman
councillor mrs weston
no i'm for chairman council wilkinson
now in fortune councillor williams
airman and four thank you councillor
wilson
no and four thank you councillor whatton
oh paul thank you chairman
members those three recommendations have
been agreed no recorded vote
32 votes for one abstention
none against thank you member
members i would like to move a motion
without notice according to council
procedure rule 14
bracket end close bracket to extend this
meeting beyond
two and a half hours for as long as
practical in order to complete the
business
can i have a second to please
i'll second that thank you councillor
weston
members we should take a vote on that
please indicate
how you wish to vote when i call your
name
councillor mrs belton no recorded vote
for councillor mrs butcher
no recorded voting for councillor
thank you thank you councillor mrs
carter
thank you no i'm for
myself no recorded vote and four
councillor
fd 94 thank you chairman
councillor eves no and four
although i would like to advise that if
it goes on beyond how boston i will have
to leave
council mrs gooding now i'm four thank
you chair
councillor hazelwood no one for
council hookway
thank you chairman uh before i vote i'd
like to um
ask that uh a comfort break um
take place at some time uh fairly soon
and um
that uh um whether the claim is actually
gonna put a
a time on this uh as to whether
it gets beyond a certain time as to
whether we have another vote thank you
it's as soon as practical counter
hookway
so the timing will be monitored
depending on how we progress
um let me take this vote complete this
vote
and i'll consider the break councillor
hudson
how do you wish to vote yeah uh well
i'll stay in on that basis thank you
for both
uh yes
council hudson harry cory vote
and for the motion thank you
no recorded vote and four
councillor lucas gill no
and for chairman thank you councillor
mrs lumley
no and four council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no recorded vote
and
i will give my apologies at 10 i will be
leaving then so obviously i'm
going to see extension thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
uh no and four thank you chairman
councillor merrick
no and four councillor mill
no and four
shaw no and for thank you chairman
council smith i recorded vote for
the answer sparing no and four council
stanley
no recorded vote and four but i should
be leaving at
ten o'clock thank you council steptoe
noted for council ward
no one for charity that's the web
no and four thank you chairman
known for chairman thank you council
wilkinson
no fortune councilor williams
no one four thank you chairman
councillor wilson
no and four councillor wootton
thank you chairman thank you i can't
come back to you
okay
members that motion has been passed no
recorded vote 31
for one abstention and one against thank
you
members as requested by councillor
hawkway i shall a joint adjourn the
meeting for five minutes
for a comfort break i shall come back to
you in five minutes members thank you
oh
oh this is fun
remember we're still being recorded
okay
members are still one or two members to
come back to us
hopefully it won't take too long
[Music]
oh where's the glasses going
members i shall re reconvene eating
and take item eight bracket five close
bracket
report of the review committee
regulation of investigary powers
act 2000 bracket ripper close bracket
council sparing vice chairman of review
committee will introduce this report
councillor sparing thank you chairman
those members will be aware this is
basically a very routine item that we
bring
to forwards for council um
most of the other say most all the
amendments that are in the policy
are set out on our behalf uh the areas
where we
become involved is where individuals
names may be changed for whatever reason
and basically chairman as far as i'm
aware i don't think
the district council has ever actioned
on this
uh statutory power we have but we are
obliged to review it
therefore on that basis i would make
that agree that the recommendation
that the amendments to the council's
ripper policy
set out in section six of appendix one
be approved by the council chairman
thank you thank you council sparing is
there a second of members
i kept second that case champion thank
you council wilkinson
members are there any questions on this
item
i can not see anybody indicating they
wish to have a question
we will therefore
you've muted again chairman
members i cannot see anybody wishing to
speak on this item we should also take a
we shall therefore take a vote on the
recommendation
by roll call when i call your name you
know the procedure
counselor mrs belton no in four
thank you counselor mrs butcher
no and for chairman the answer canal
no and for chairman thank you councillor
carter
now and for chairman thank you
councillor mrs carter
thank you recorded though and a fourth
thank you
myself now recorded bowdoin for
councillor fd
known for chairman thank you councillor
eves
thank you thanks to mrs gooding
no and four thank you chairman council
hazelwood
no one for thank you councillor hawkway
no and four thank you council hudson
no recorded voting for the motion thank
you counselor ionu
no recorder vote and for the motion
councillor
lucas gill no and for chairman
councillor mrs lumley no and for
councillor mrs mason
and no and for the motion thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson no and four
thank you chairman
thousand merrick no and four
councillor meown no and four
counselor mrs pavling no i'm thor
thank you councillor mrs rowe thank you
chairman no
end for councillor mrs shaw
thank you council smith now recorded
vote
for thank you council sparing no and
four
council stanley no and four
council steptoe no and four
council award no and four thank you jim
thank you council webb no and four thank
you chairman
thanks for mrs weston and four chairman
council wilkinson known for christian
council williams it's no
and four thank you chairman council
wilson
no and four and the council woodson
four thank you chairman thank you
members
members there will not be a recorded
vote unanimously approved thank you
member
members we now take item 86
a report of the investment board max 1
maximizing the potential of cherry
orchard jubilee country park
council steptoe chairman of the
investment board will introduce this
item
council steptoe thank you chairman um as
you say
there's two two recommendations two lots
of recommendations on this paper
uh we'll take them individually i assume
um
it's fairly self-explanatory the uh
looking at the potential of cherry
orchard park to maximize our
returns from that looking at what events
can be put into there
and the various other things um if they
should their members have there should
any
have any questions i'm sure councillor
sorry
i'm sure marcus hutton will be more than
happy to answer any questions
but i'd like to move the recommendations
as shown uh item
2 on page
8.6.1 um
to the to the to the council
thank you council steptoe do you have a
secondary cancer step though
council walled
your beauty council award
i do apologize chairman yes i'd like to
second that thank you
thank you council award
any questions members
there are no no people end uh indicating
they wish to ask
questions i therefore propose members
that we vote on these recommendations
together
and i will assume your agreement unless
you click on the raised hand
icon no such indications members
therefore when i pull your name can you
please indicate how you wish
to vote councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote and for the
recommendations
thank you council mrs butcher
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
for the recommendation
council canal
no and four please chair thank you
councillor mr carter
no and for chairman thank you thank you
councillor mrs carter
thank you chair um no and four
thank you myself never recorded voting
for the motion
counselor fd four and four chairman
thank you
thank you councillor eves
thank you chair counselor mrs gooding
no i'm four thank you chairman
councillor hazelwood
no one for councillor hawkway
sorry chairman uh no and for
councillor hudson no
councillor mrs mason
no land for councillor mrs mcpherson
no and for alistair merrick
no and four
thank you councillor mrs rowe thank you
chairman no and for
thank you council mrs shaw
no inform mr chairman councillor smith
now recorded vote for council sparing
no and four council stanley
no m4 council steptoe
open for council award
no and four thank you council webb
no and four thank you chairman mr mrs
weston
council wilkinson known for chairman
councillor williams that's known for
thank you chairman
councillor wilson no n4
council
no recorded vote thank you member
members i shall now take item two of
this item
the council's local authority trading
camp companies
council steptoe chairman of the
investing board investment ball will
introduce
this report councillor steptoe
thank you chairman uh yes again it's
fairly self-explanatory
uh the documentation is fairly
self-explanatory
uh there was a question at the um
investment board meeting
as to whether we should consider two
directors of the holding company
uh officers are looking into the
practicalities of that and etc will be
reporting back to the investment
investment board in due course um
i would like to remind members that if
they do wish to ask any questions
on the appendices uh that the council
will have to go into
uh private and confidential because of
the because of the confidentiality of
documents
but if there are any questions um dawn
dawn tribe is here this evening
i'm sure that she'll be able to answer
any questions on that basis chairman i
will move the recommendation
at four point one on page eight point
six point one
thank you council step two council ward
yes uh thank you chairman i'm happy to
uh second that uh recommendation and
proposal thank you thank you council
meet again members
as mentioned by council steptoe there
are two exempt appendices to the report
and before i open this up to questions
please be reminded
that you do need to make if you do need
to make reference to either of the
exempt appendices
it will be necessary to move a
recommendation to exclude the press
and public are there any members
wishing to ask a question
there is no indication of such members
the recommendation uh then as council
steptoe said there is one that the
accounts of the latkos
for the financial year 2019 stroke 2020
set out in this exact report be
be approved the voting will be by
roll paul and again you know the
procedure members when i call your name
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote and four councillor mrs
butcher
no recorded vote and four thank you
chairman
councillor no recorded vote
for thank okay you carter
no m4 thank you chairman
councillor mrs carter
thank you chair no and thank you myself
no recorded vote and four councillor fd
known for thank you chairman councillor
eves
councillor mrs gooding no recorded vote
and for the motion thank you chairman
thank you councillor hazelwood
no one for councillor hawkway
recorded vote and for
hudson no recorded vote for the motion
thank you councillor iot no recorded
vote and for the motion
thank you council lucas gill
no and for german councillor mrs lumley
no and four thank you councillor mrs
mason
no and for councillor mrs mcpherson
no and four thank you chairman
councilmerick
no and four councillor meal
known for chairman thank you councillor
pavling mrs pavling
nine four thank you councillor mrs rowe
no and for sorry chairman thank you
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman known for cancer
smith
no recorded vote for house and sparing
no and four council stanley
no and four councillor steptoe
no and four councillor ward
known for chairman thank you thank you
council webb
no and four thank you also mrs weston
and four chairman council wilkinson
no unfortunate councillor williams
chairman no and four council wilson
no and four councillor woodson
every chair no no in four thank you
yes thank you members
that's unanimous in favor of the
recommendation and there's no recorded
vote
members i shall now take item nine on
the agenda report on urgent urgent
decisions
is this noted members i will assume
agreement unless anyone clicks on the
raised
hand icon
there's no such indication that's been
agreed thank you members
chairman you're muted again sorry
agenda item 10 report of the leader on
the work of the executive
chairman you keep muting chairman you
keep muting yourself
not too sure why i'm not muting myself i
don't know why it's happening
um counselor council watching will
provide a verbal update to council on
the work of the executives since the
last full
council meeting councilwood
councillor button councilwood you are
muted
yeah i think that's another pound in the
box apologies um
right i'm pleased to uh provide an
update
uh on the work of the executive um
members
the meeting has already received the
minutes of the meetings of the executive
since our last full council meeting on
14th of july
i'm happy to provide an update for
information purposes
on the business dealt with by the
executive since then
at its meeting on the 2nd of september
the executive
agreed the quarter 1 20 20 21
revenue budget and capital position
approved a drawdown
of 20 000 pounds from the council's
earmarked reserves
towards an appraisal of the options for
the delivery
of the council's grounds maintenance and
street cleansing services
including the potential delivery of a
joint contract
by ggt it approves the award
of a new materials recovery facilities
contract to viridor from the 4th of
november
and at its meeting on the 7th of october
the executive
agreed to the council's participation in
a south essex no use empty scheme
subject to a joint bid for getting
building fund financing from the south
east local enterprise partnership being
successful
it agreed the investment of up to 17 000
pounds in match funding towards
loans to develop suitable empty
properties identified within the
rockford district
area moving on to portfolio holder
decisions
which have been taken it was agreed that
the
closure of the ict migration project
agreed the allocation of voluntary
sector grants for this financial year
responded to two government planning
consultations on changes
to the current planning system following
the
white paper and designated care levers
as a group of council taxpayers defined
common by a common set of circumstances
for the purposes of the discretionary
reduction in council tax liability
policy
for the current financial year that
completes my report thank you chairman
thank you council woodson members is
that noted
no hands indicating otherwise thank you
council woodson
members that has been noted i'll now
take
agender item 11 motions on notice
of which there are none members
agenda item 12 update on the association
of south
essex local authorities a sailor and
local government reorganization
council wooden will introduce this
report
counselor wootton thank you chairman uh
i'm pleased to introduce this report
soon after i became leader i promised
council
that at the earliest opportunity i would
bring a report on the work of the
association of south essex local
authorities as seller two members
i am grateful to sean scrap the managing
director for the preparation of this
report
this report is the start of what will in
future be regular reporting to members
on the work
of a seller when i became leader i
confessed to being
unclear what the benefits of membership
of a seller
were for watchful district council no
secret that i was concerned
about the transparency of decision
making
when only a memorandum of understanding
is in place
and accountability for funds that
rochford district council had invested
in the venture
i was also concerned that from a seller
to date
frankly has been poor i've made it a
priority to address these issues
and i'm pleased to report progress is
being made
i am supportive of collaboration between
the six
the seller authorities made all the more
impressive
especially because there are different
political affiliations
coming together and striving with a
common objective
for the greater benefit and good of
south essex
south essex has historically been
overlooked for investment compared to
authorities in the north of the county
the asylum growth prospectus is
something i can stand behind
and use to lobby government it is a good
piece of work
which clearly articulates the
opportunities for south essex
of which the district would surely
benefit
whilst i and the administration were
absolutely clear that the growth
prospectus
should not be the basis on which
governance for the component authorities
is decided
under the reform agenda especially as
central government have deferred the
publication
of the white paper on this subject it is
nevertheless a matter
which will inevitably become topical at
some point again in the future
being part of a seller will put us in a
good position
to know neighbour authority thinking and
to deal
and take an informed view in the best
interest
of the rocha district and its residents
a great deal of assurance has been
provided to me which increases my
confidence in this joint working
opportunity
that the underlying administration of a
seller its own
governance and its communications needs
further work
i believe i can do this from within
having set the wheels in motion already
but i don't just expect members to take
it from me
i will promise to bring update reports
back
at least twice a year about the progress
being made by a seller
i am convinced that asela done the right
way
can be a force for good and the rochford
district council will benefit
from participation but only if we can
address those things
which undermine members confidence and
get in the way of doing business
thank you chairman and with that unless
there's any questions
we'll turn to uh item 10 but i see that
there is a
hand from councillor eats
thank you councillor watson councillor
eve
thank you chair um i read the
report with uh a good deal of interest
it's a very comprehensive report
um there are a few questions and a few
points i'd like to
raise as a result of that 7.1
states that we'll be paying 60 000
pounds as a subscription to a seller
uh yearly this is uh allowed in our next
year's budget tool shows in our next
year's budget
could you remind me of when the council
agreed to that figure
and that's when that's my first question
uh skipping down to the attached report
on the glossy report produced by a
seller
going to page 12.9 homes and places
the preceding reports are very
convincing
and do sound very good but i quote
from the homes and places report in in
quotes
put in place a complete suite of
up-to-date local plans
supported by the south essex plan close
quote
my question there is what comes first
the district local plans or the south
essex plan uh that is quite important to
understand
because uh it's going to indicate
who is going to have priority in saying
what we actually have to have building
wise in our area
to continue again
quoting from the same page quotes
completely transform housing delivery in
the region
close quotes with another quote
commitment to a program of strategic and
tactical interventions close quotes
sounds very much like the decisions will
be made by a seller not
rdc that would mean that the people who
voted for us to be in place
would effectively have no voice in the
housing delivery
we think it's bad now if this is
implemented in the form laid out in the
report before us my considered opinion
is that rdc
will have little power to object to
schemes being implemented in our
district
should we disagree with any particular
schemes
another quote on the same page over the
last six months
south essex have been working with homes
england on a joint delivery program
close quote my question there is have
rdc officers been involved
in that work if so our officers will
know the proposals
for housing in the area because they
will have been discussed according to
this report
so i think it would be good business for
the council to be updated
on those proposals sooner rather than
later
however if we as rdc have not been
involved
it would serve to underline the growing
concerns over what seems to be shaping
up
to be bullying rdc into the project as
and as such i on behalf of my
constituents would have great difficulty
in supporting the proposals going
forward on that basis
agreed the project is highly ambitious
but as members representing our
community we should be asking ourselves
at what cost to the rotsford district
my fear is that due to the large areas
of greenbelt in our district that other
adjoining areas
do not have and in the light of the
highly questionable changes to the
planning system
that are currently going through
parliament the rockford district will be
forced
to bear the brunt of any proposed
developments through the acela project
and therefore lose its current status as
a desirable
rural area to live i for one
remain yet to be convinced on the
overall benefits of this project
will bring to the rochester district
thank you count uh
chairman thank you yes councillor
woodson do you wish to comment on those
points
thank you chairman uh clearly that is a
prepared statement with a number of
issues raised in it
um i have to say that i was not a leader
at the time that the growth prospectus
was prepared
um but the document was i believe
circulated two or three months ago
actually
um prior to it being submitted in
respect
of i think council reeves first question
and we pay into the seller group
60 000 pounds a year so far
we've paid three years subscriptions uh
which is 180 000 pounds so that is if
you like
the cost of being a member of the a
seller group
in terms of the local plan the local
plan
will always take precedence over
anything
with the seller you know that is just
simply the uh
the fact that it is our local plan it is
elect which always will trump the a
seller
vision um the acceleration is a bit of a
long term
um you know by definition of that growth
prospectus um
it's talking many years ahead but i am
actually going to ask the managing
director
sean scrapped if he has anything to add
because he was certainly
part of the um
the time when that growth perspective
was being put together and he may have
something to add to
my comments mr stratton with you do you
wish to comment
chairman thank you um i suppose the key
point i would make
about the discussions that have taken
place and are taking place with holmes
england about
investment in south essex is that those
relate to
sites that are in the pipeline as it as
it were
it's not relating to uh future
allocations
at uh at this stage so it's a question
of having
a discussion with homes england to see
what investment can be brought from
government
to unlock the sites across south essex
and including in rockford and an example
of that would be the
standbridge mills site which is sitting
waiting to be developed
using homes england money to unlock the
blockages and to bring forward those
sites and contribute towards the housing
in in south essex and in rochester
thank you chairman thank you mr strotton
uh councillor hookway
thank you chairman um yeah um
if i heard that counselor wouldn't
correct me uh there seems to
be a number of matters which are still
yet to be resolved in the uh the
the structure of uh seller and i'm
concerned that um there are still
governance issues outstanding
um in relation to uh this organization
um and um i would uh would like
for uh councillor wootton to
try to get the government's matters
resolved as soon as possible
before any uh decisions uh uh which
affect
our districts uh start to start to be
made
thank you guys i thought councilwood
would you like to comment on that
chairman i think that's an absolutely
fair point and i think um
a seller itself would now acknowledge
that it has gone as far as it can under
the existing memorandum of understanding
um it needs to
it is not a decision-making body and
that is
really where uh i have had some concerns
that it was
moving ahead as if it was speaking for
authorities
without the governance process in place
and actually referring back to the
authorities
that they represent so i i think that's
a perfectly fair point
and uh it's something that within a
seller
i'm certainly working to achieve with my
leader colleagues
my other five leader colleagues thank
you councilwood council ward
yeah thank you very much chairman yeah i
think um you know
the point that council hookway makes is
shared by the majority
of members on on our side uh to be
honest i mean that's why the big push
was looking at really uncovering as much
as we could
in regards to what was going on uh i
admit i was part
uh initially uh working with uh uh
councillor cutler um and i deputised for
him on this
and i think the most important thing to
realize with regard to a sailor
and how it came together considering how
different
all the various districts are and
boroughs
within a sailor the the i would say that
the cement that would be holding us
together was the necessity to bring in
infrastructure
and i think that was the most important
thing that has kept us together
how do we get infrastructure into south
essex
because this is the one thing that i'm
constantly asked about by
you know local residents and i'm sure
all of us across
the political divide so to speak you
know
are needing to get infrastructure into
our district
uh and into our area as quickly as
possible and we need to be able to
facilitate
that infrastructure so you know again
the governance issue is very important
how we go forward
and this is how can i say it's
it's a very fluid situation in where we
are
trying to understand and come together
between ourselves how we manage this
we've got a fantastic plan going forward
basically as councillor wooden i think
has has said
it's a fantastic shopping list of
requirements we want
but ultimately we have to find a good
way
of bringing us all together to be able
to enable that plan to come together
thank you chairman thank you council
award
council sparing thank you chairman
uh taking on ball all the lovely ideas
that have been highlighted
getting down to the nuts and bolts when
we
recently started asking questions about
governance suddenly we found that we
created a momentum
that other groups joined us
we have prioritized creating our
producing our local plan as have
all the other councils involved the one
item that came up time and time again
from
from what councillor wooden came back
with and conversations that we overheard
every council wanted to take
responsibility for planning
in their own areas whether it be us
thorough
south end or whatever nobody wanted to
be part
of some master plan yes we need the
infrastructure
but if you recall from the presentations
we received
everybody was adamant that they
controlled their own planning within
their own district
i think there is we are
better to work with this group and i've
been very cynical about the whole
process
i don't think there's very been very
much accountability in the past
i think we're moving forward on that but
at the end of the day
as far as i'm aware and councillor wood
might correct me on this
at the moment we haven't signed up to
anything
and if we found that that this was
not working to the benefits of the
district and i don't think we'd be on
our own
then the thing wouldn't progress thank
you chairman
thank you council sparing councillor fd
thank you chairman uh just the point
that councillor he's made on our green
belt
um where's the plan in authority have no
control
over who put scene planning applications
so
i feel it would be much better to be
part of a seller
and not have those
if something comes forward being done to
us without having some say in it
thank you thank you councillor fd
members
i cannot see anybody else indicating
they wish to speak
yes councillor woodson
thank you chairman um i'd just like to
come back and sort of make the point
that
uh three months into my leadership this
is actually the first detailed report
that we've
considered on the work of a seller um
but we're certainly not there yet
and i wanted a very open transparent and
honest
um position so i don't do not want
members in any way uh misled in thinking
that everything in the garden of a
seller is absolutely rosy
and i've been quite clear that i want to
be much better on the financial
accountability
uh on the communication uh on the
governance
on all of those sides so this is work in
progress
and i'm not going to hide away from that
and i've been very very clear with him
with my seller colleagues on that but i
do not want us to lose sight of the fact
that this is a collaboration
between six authorities that probably
would not actually speak to other
each other in the way that a seller does
work together
and we have got to recognize that the
economic potential
of south essex is undersold at the
present time
and this is a huge opportunity if we
manage to get the governance right
the funding the accountability of the
communication right
this is a huge opportunity for us to
turn things around
and really get huge benefits from a
seller
and other bodies that are lobbying for
this part of
essex thank you chairman thank you
councillor woodson
members there's no other member
indicating their wishes to speak
there are two recommendations for noting
as set out
at paragraph 10.1 of the report on page
12.3
as follows one to note and support
progress on the acella growth and
recovery plans as set out in the
prospectus july 2020
and two to note and support the
preparation of an evidence base to feed
into deliberations
on local government reorganization
following the publication of the
devolution and local recovery white
paper
members are they noted i will assume
your agreement unless anyone clicks on
the
raised hang icon
has been noted members thank you very
much
members i shall now take a agenda item
13 allocation of seats on the committees
miss angela law assistant director legal
and democratic
will introduce this report
miss law
thank you the council has a statute of
duty by virtue of the local government
and housing acts 1989 to ensure that the
appointments to committee
reflect uh the proportion of total
numbers
on the council held by each political
group unless otherwise agreed
following the change political
composition has to
has been recalculated and the allocation
of seats are in accordance with the act
the new committee composition has set
out an appendix one and the nominations
to the new composition is set out in the
addendum to this report
chairman the recommendations are set out
under paragraph six on page
13.2 uh however german is a slight
amendment to
to being that members be appointed to
serve on committees for the remainder
of the 2021
municipal year as detailed in the
addendum to this report thank you
chairman
thank you um angela law any questions
members
no hands members there's no one wishing
indicating they wish to speak members i
met i propose to that we vote on these
recommendations together and i will
assume your agreement unless anyone
clicks on the raised hand icon
there's been no such indication members
so when i call your name please indicate
how you wish to
to vote counselor mrs belton
no recorded vote and for the
recommendations
thank you councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and four thank you
councillor cannell
no in the four thank you chair
councillor mr carter
now i'm four thank you gentlemen thank
you councillor mrs carter
thank you chair no i'm four myself no
recorded vote and for the
recommendations
counselor fd known for thank you
chairman
councillor eves thank you
thank you councillor mrs gooding no
recorded vote and for the motion thank
you chairman
councillor hazelwood no one for
councillor hawkway no recorded vote and
for
councillor hudson no and before
councillor ionu
i'll come back to you councillor lucas
gill
no and four thank you gentlemen
councillor mrs lumley
no and four councillor mrs mcpherson
no and four thank you councillor merrick
no and four councillor mealed
no and four councillor
mrs pavling no i'm four
rowe thank you chairman now and for
thank you councillor mr shaw
thank you chairman known for councillor
smith
now recorded vote for justice sparing
no and for counselors stanley
he's not here okay he's gone counselor
open for thank you council ward
no and four channels thank you council
webb
no and four thank you chairman okay so
this is weston
no i'm four chairman councillor wilson
unfortunately councilor williams
no and four thank you chairman council
woodson
thank you chairman councillor ionu
i'm sorry cancer wilson my apologies
councillor wilson
sorry chairman no end for councillor
ionu are you around
i'm just looking to see consulate this
is still here you see
councillor i own you can you repeat your
your vote please
cancel i own you okay no
not to worry that's unanimous uh
nicely approved chairman
members that's been passed um no
recorded vote
unanimous vote of 29 4 thank you members
members i shall now take item 14 on the
agenda
and on your gender council
representation on the bradley
b community forum miss
angela law assistant director legal and
democratic will introduce the report
angela law thank you chairman
the bride well-being project is
he's proposing to build a new nuclear
power station at gradual and state and
he's establishing a community forum
in order to help engage with the
community and key organizations
an invitation of our power generation
country limited has been extended to the
council to appoint one member
and their substitute to attend meetings
of the new bradwell d community forum
it is anticipated the community forum
will meet on a quarterly basis and the
intensity of means
to share information about the project
and to facilitate questions and
discussions and feedback
we've received one nomination to the
forum and nomination
to the forum set out the addendum to
this report chairman there is a slight
amendment to the recommendation to now
state
to appoint one to a point one member and
one substitute member to the bradwell b
community forum as detailed in the
addendum to the report thank you
chairman
thank you to the law are there any
members questions yeah
no being indicated our members is
one recommendation is set out on
paragraph 8.1
on page 14.2 of the report that one
member and one substitute member be
appointed to the bradwell b community
forum as detailed in the addendum to the
report
i will propose it from the chair is
there
a second to please first second
chair thank you
members voting will be right roll call
of names
you know the procedure councilor mrs
belton
no recorded vote for councillor mrs
butcher
no recorded vote and four councillor
canal
no and four thank you chair councillor
mr carter
no thank you
councillor mrs carter
hey chair no recorded by i am for
myself no recorded vote and four
councillor fd
mary called you voting for thank you
chairman councillor eves
councillor gooding no recorded voting
for the motion thank you
councillor hazelwood no one for
councillor hawkway no recorded vote and
for
thank you councillor hudson now recorded
voting for the motion
councillor ionu
council lucas gill no and ford
chairman councillor mrs lumley
no and four councillor mrs mcpherson
no and four thank you councillor merrick
no and four councillor milne
and no and for councillor mrs pavlin
unknown for thank you councillor mrs
rowe
thank you chairman now and for
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman known for councillor
smith
now recorded vote for councillor
spurring
no and for councillor steptoe
known for council ward
no i'm four thank you chairman
councillor webb
now and four thank you council mrs
weston
no i'm four german council wilkinson
94 chairman thank you council williams
iv thank you councillor wilson no and
full chairman
and councillor wooden thank you chairman
thank you members
unanimously 30 votes for none against no
abstentions
members before we conclude the business
for this meeting
this will be sean stratton's last
council meeting before he retires at the
end of the month
sean joined the council on the 14th of
october 1985 as a planning assistant
and has undertaken a variety of roles
including as head of planning
and transportation for a number of years
before being promoted to director
and finally to managing director on the
27th of june
2016. i know that you will all wish to
join me in thanking sean
for his many years of service to the
council
and the district of rochford and wishing
him all the very best
for the future and his retirement
members does anybody else wish to say a
few words
uh hi bush i will chairman
both ties
[Laughter]
council hudson were you indicating you
wish to speak i am trying yes
i've i've worked with sean with
a two-year gap for 19 years uh
i have such respect for him and his
ability to assimilate information
which left me uh lacking and i thought i
was pretty good
nothing like sean this council and this
district
will miss him greatly thank you for
everything you've done sean
thank you council hudson council steptoe
thank you chairman uh council hudson has
said
very much what i wanted to say myself i
haven't worked with sean
quite as long but i first met sean
when i served on the standards committee
as parish representatives many years ago
now
it has been very very he's been very
very helpful
towards me he's been very supportive
and as somebody's already mentioned his
his bow ties
sometimes left a little bit to be
desired
but generally speaking i found him more
than more than helpful
and i for one will miss him greatly and
i wish him all the best for his uh
future endeavors thank you council
steptoe councillor mrs butcher
yes uh thank you chairman yes i'd like
to say that
um i first met sean at christmas 1988
when um i was one of his neighbors
uh we shared uh some bottles of wine
and i'd like to say he did have some
competition for his uh
bow ties at that time so um
and then of course i re-met him again
when i was on the council so
i just want to wish him and his family
every good luck for the future and it's
been a pleasure working with him and
knowing him as a neighbour
and as a friend
councillor williams
no no nothing to say really rather than
thank you sean for everything that
you've done thank you
councillor woodson
thank you chairman um i thought it was
appropriate to let others that will have
known sean a lot longer than i
uh to have their say first but a very
sincere
uh good wishes from me sean
for a very happy retirement uh thank you
for your support in the
relatively for the very short time that
we have worked together
i wish you well thank you very much
indeed
thank you councilwood and council smith
thank you chairman um i think i'm one of
the slightly older ones as far as
council service goes
uh and i i've i've been lucky enough to
uh
work with sean uh particularly with what
seems to have
been one of my homes as planet as
chairing planning committee on
on a good number of occasions and i i i
absolutely we we've all benefited from
sean's enthusiasm
um an energy
when it comes to advising and helping us
with
with planning a good number of us know
that sean's a man of
many many talents um
you know we we know he likes to dress up
in leather
um splash around in the water
and uh i'm sure he will find ways
of keeping himself more than busy and
fit
and healthy uh in the future thank you
sean
good luck thank you smith sean would you
like to say a few words
yes thank you chairman and and thank you
members for your comments uh
very much appreciated and it has been a
privilege to work for
a goodly part of my career in local
government
at rochford i hope to say i've seen many
changes over those years
but i'd just like to thank members and
officers that i've worked with
throughout that time who've provided a
tremendous support
and encouragement um i know we're living
through
challenging times but i wish you all
well
and i'll be watching from the sidelines
so thank you
thank you sean
members thank you all for attending and
thank you for your patience and
forbearing
i declare the meeting closed
at 10 34. thank you members
very good